welcome back to CBS s morning I'm Gayle
King with Anthony Mason and Tony to
copal we are hearing from one of the
jurors who convicted Harvey Weinstein of
two felony sex crimes the disgrace of
Hollywood mogul spent the night in the
hospital again last night after being
taken there in an ambulance shortly
after the verdict was read the other day
his attorney said that he suffered chest
pains
Jericka Duncan was in court covering the
trial and joins us now with more on the
story what's the latest well we know
that Weinstein is being treated for
heart palpitations and high blood
pressure this morning jurors who were
part of that historic trial are now
finally settling back into their normal
lives one juror asking not to be named
is speaking out about the experience I
felt like my heart was literally gonna
pop out of my chest juror number two
told inside edition tensions in the
deliberation room were very high as they
reached a decision to convict former
Hollywood mogul Harvey Weinstein on two
of five charges every last women that
took the stand I wish them the best I
hope that this is now a chapter that
they could close after five days of
deliberations the jury found Weinstein
guilty of rape in the third degree and a
criminal sexual act in the first degree
involving two women he was not convicted
on the most serious charge predatory
sexual assault but still faces up to 29
years in prison we will continue to
fight the focus now shifts to Los
Angeles where Weinstein faces four
additional felony charges for rape and
sexual assault dating back to 2013 party
you messed with the wrong women we will
see you here in Los Angeles where
hopefully your conviction will leave you
in jail for life on the steps of City
Hall in Los Angeles Tuesday women who
call themselves the silence breakers
said they hope in the city where the
oscar-winning producer built his career
he will find himself a convicted felon
once again around 100 women have come
forward to accused Weinstein of sexual
misconduct among them
TV anchor Lauren Sivan probably
definitely has health problems but that
does not mean
that he should escape justice Sivan said
she's now confident Weinstein will be
found guilty in LA all the women that
you tried to silence for the last 30
years those are the ones that put you in
jail Weinstein is supposed to be
sentenced in New York on March 11th but
one of his attorney said they are trying
to get that moved up why because they
say his team plans to file an appeal but
that cannot be done until his sentence
is complete the Los Angeles DA's office
is still not saying when it plans to
move forward only to say it will
definitely proceed so this case
definitely not over not over for
Weinstein write Eureka thank you